first of all we got to talk about this
suit you look thank you very much it was
a story recommendation my stylist I told
I told him that I would be in the Lamas
and I need something fresh something new
and he he showed me choices and when I
saw when I wash this this soothing
in a photo was I said to myself I want
this this JLo suit I show to my wife and
my wife Senora like it not only I kiss
too much brighter and I told her believe
me it's gonna be huge people will be
talking about it okay and look are you
giving me a run for my money see we got
the bright I gotta tell you 1998
suavemente that was my jam I mean do you
get ever tired of that song oh that's
that's my aim my superheat
I am the songwriter and very blessed
with with this song in my repertory and
it and that gave me the opportunity to
to present new music with new new guys
right now I am nominee with a subpoena
with a Steve Aoki daddy giant defense
news and and I feel blessed with that
yeah daddy Yankees being the icon award
tonight what makes him so deserving of
that now he decided his he's are
incredible he's he's he's very talent
but he's very humble humble guy and I
feel happy with this
finally tonight you know they got all
female hosts tonight for the first time
what's it like because you know Latin
music is sometimes male-dominated what's
it like to see the women get there dude
this is the woman moment and I'm happy
I'm happy because I if I am you know TV
show wise I watched five woman and the
host hosting the show I say oh my god
great that does raise that's great
that's what I feel a girl power
[Music]
[Applause]